nine players are to be divided into two
teams of four and one umpire there you
go have anyways so we start without
restrictions fair enough okay no let's
think about this I always begin with a
diagram okay even if you don't end up
filling up the diagram with much it
helps you conceptually visualize what's
going on okay so I have two teams of
four so here's one team he's another
team and then he's out of pile
okay so you got team a team B and more
know if that would have been me
so what do you do here this is not that
hot it's not that hard you think about
it step by step okay let's have a look
at team a shall we I need to put four
people on it how many do I have to
choose from I am going to choose from
remember there are no restrictions
whatsoever I can pick any of them right
so this is say zapatti
so to begin with I've got nitrous pour
okay so then I move on to the next team
how many people do I have like left to
choose from I've got five f20 and how
many of them do I need to pick four okay
then I have the umpire right how many
people do I have left to choose from one
and I have to choose what okay now
that's it let's notice a few things
before we actually compute this okay
number one of course he actually didn't
need to worry about this one choose one
did you why not well firstly numerically
because it is one but why is it
numerically one why does it not make it
impact because once you've picked your
two teams there are no more choices
right that last guy is the umpire no
matter what right so that's why you
don't need to worry about him I ran him
down because I'm trying to demonstrate
my understanding of the situation and
there is a spot to fill and there's only
one way to fill it okay
additionally do you notice
I didn't have to do it this way right
suppose I had drawn my diagram like this
now you might be thinking at this point
what's the difference and the answer is
not much it's the same scenario right
but just replay it with me
okay how do I work out this probability
well you're gonna still start with
teammate that's 9 choose oh right and
then you go ahead and you pick an umpire
how many people do I have left to pick
from I have 5 I have 5 people who I can
choose to be the umpire but then at that
point you're in the same scenario where
before you've got to fill a team of four
and you've got exactly four people to do
it with and there's only one way to do
that right hmm so I mean you know these
are both one they are the unimportant
part right once you pick these two
you're stuck with whoever's left they've
got to go in the remaining spots okay
and then of course you've got these two
which of course we just showed are the
same because of the symmetry there right
you might as well pick four people to be
on a team or one person to not be on a
team okay
sorry if I'm fixate on this you can see
this is very personal all right let's
just go ahead let's work out what the
number is can you tell me what the
number is going cruncher throughthe 600
and thing okay now here's the problem
um we're wrong well I mean the numbers
right the calculator was fine okay but
something is wrong there are far too
many Arrangements okay now it's not just
because I know you know this is a
situation which like I said it happens
at lunch all the time and you waste the
first 15 minutes of lunch trying white
guy who's not much attainment cetera and
I'm like no way is there this made on
with combinations could otherwise would
it be different every time they're far
less than that okay and the problem is
what have we not accounted for what have
we missed now I hope you try and get it
without just telling it to you maybe
maybe it jumps out at you okay I want
you to think back to my situation with
the four-digit pin okay now we come back
to me and I'm like I care about
permutations and I care about water so I
think about this right I catch it I
clutch it through and then I work out
okay
you know this is without replacement so
I come up with sorry 10 I couple from
this okay and then I hand it to you and
you say well some of these are good but
tons of them are actually the same
because you only care about which four
numbers there are you don't care about
which order they're in
okay so can you see there's an order
here that I'm gonna hand to you I'm
gonna hand you these 630 teams and an
umpire arrangements right and you're
gonna look at some of them and say these
are the same these are the same teams
what if we missed
can anyone has anyone noticed it yet in
the last two minutes of them talking
uh-huh right I will put to you for
example right I put the first well I
just I just did in an order you know
first it's for their you know your next
four here and then the last guy okay
there's one of my arrangements and then
another of my arrangements I start
picking completely differently and I end
up with you know five six seven and
eight over here one two three and four
over here and of course the loner and
you come to me and say but those are the
same teams you've just you've just put
them on opposite sides of the field but
they're the same teams okay so I have
over counted by what factor should put
it
I should put it here hey that's the real
number of ways okay because there is an
order there which I was putting on to it
this a and B business which isn't there
you don't care about that you just want
the combination so you divide by two
factorial and that gives you 350